five topics and then a freestyle wrap so
topic number one is going to come from
this section over here what would you
like a rap about friends Benjamin
Benjamin Britton the composer
why did you look like I just thwarted
you then
Benjamin so Benjamin Britton are we is
he early 20th century or late late 19th
mid 20th oh really okay cool no one else
knows who he is but if you're a fan of
Edward Elgar then you know he's relevant
to that
um okay cool it's uh there's definitely
never been a wrap-up Benjamin Britain
before I wish I'd miss her junior said
Benjamin Button because they'd at least
love that the Benjamin Britton the the
famed English composer and I assume
conductor uh love this stuff what a
prick you are
Red's got pianos and he doesn't even
know who the [__] it is
cool well let's come let's come to this
side next I guess
skewomorphism Can we cancel this rep Now
red please
foreign
thing is I've heard this word and I know
when I heard it I went oh I should learn
what that means because someone will
probably come up with a wrapper that is
it the is it the thing that Apple used
to do where you design things after
their function or something so yeah yeah
so okay can you describe it for a
general audience in like a sentence now
floppy disk for saving a file a floppy
yeah okay so yeah so like the icon for
saving a file is a floppy disk even
though that's no longer needed this is
gonna be the shortest rap ever
literally I'm gonna rhyme Benjamin
Britain an skewomorphic and leave so
let's get a suggestion number three from
the front middle of the room
okay there were there were two
Indianapolis
great never been there
and then did you say Power Rangers at
the back yeah okay my mum didn't let me
watch that so that's good
red I'm [__] I'm [__] red I'm [__]
we need one one final one to top off
well okay so thank you thank you for
saying pineapples down there that was
amazing like a lot I'll throw in that
bone
um are you yelling doctors at the back
is that a suggestion or a medical
emergency
right and what else was being shouted
pimping ain't easy
[Applause]
okay well I mean that's got more of a
cheer than you did when you quietly said
911 over there
[Laughter]
okay I think we've got enough I mean I'm
gonna try my best to actually rap about
the first four things Power Rangers
Indianapolis skewomorphism and Benjamin
Britain and then doctors and pimping
ain't easy we'll we'll probably oh and
pineapple stop adding more red
okay and pineapple look I'll try and
remember all of those uh well if if
accidentally I forget the three I don't
like forgive me uh well let's let's make
up a rapper all these things and if it's
[__] frankly you only have yourself to
blame
he'll start I mean literally we'll start
with pineapple simplest thing simplest
thing of course the simplest thing fruit
We Begin gotta get the peeler removing
the skin kind of prickly like a pawpaw
or a pear with a pineapple always take
care I'm aware it makes you come better
ladies love it they're like yeah
underneath the balls dick above it they
say your Siemens exceptional I'm gonna
try your pineapple diet add in the
papaya why oh why I was really smitten
with the show going well then the
Benjamin Britain this Pro says yo Chris
I'm gonna tell this following the legacy
of Thomas Tallis about 600 years before
look at him chuckle he was like oh he's
going Full Throttle he knows about the
coral liturgy there in the orchestral
Symphony you can play this yes I can
American Copland Fanfare for the common
man but let me go back to Britain and
he's British kind of obvious from the
name we can hit this knock it out of the
park rhyme with Precision nerd at the
back skew morphism of course we're going
to ruin this today basically a floppy
disk it's how that you say are so fun an
Old Clock face moving around tick tick
yeah post haste we've really literally
no other examples that I know but that's
okay I'm sure they're at ample look it
up close show go on Wikipedia if I'd
been to Indiana but would be easier
Indiana that's the state I presume says
Chris why because you say the sea
Indianapolis the only thing that I know
is going good hasn't he got the museum
for Kurt Vonnegut that's literally the
only tourist place but all of you are
like blank face it's a disgrace
Slaughterhouse Five or cat's cradle
incredible novels yeah it's painful and
shameful I've never visited I'm sure
it's great oh I'm gonna team up me and
four of my mates a yellow on a red one a
blue one and a white we're rocking out
there for a big big fight the aliens are
coming the tiny robots they're all
strangers but Power Rangers you know we
got a massive sword we're gonna team up
we're gonna stop Optimum devices might
steam up the Pink Ranger she was really
hot isn't that true again I've never
watched it so red I'm asking you when
they were injured when it was properly
they would go there hobbling to the
doctor he would lie them down and say
simply Power Rangers stop fighting I'll
do an injury but how are they injured
I'm gonna ask you they just chopped in
the air so they just got the bruise no
bleeding there no deep Cuts pimping
ain't easy you shouted it up it's
difficult I know I tell the people it's
hard why because technically it's
illegal you can be a prostitute
self-employed but if you start employing
them then avoid the IRS they'll start
investigating cash they say that man
with a large mustache a wide brim hat a
long coat yes we see he that's the true
fact the moral pimping ain't easy it's
not
all right
[__] you